all right Zoe yes Zoe oh where'd you
grow up where are you from originally I
am from Dana Point originally OC Orange
County
tell me about your family uh my family I
was adopting my family they're um
they work you know I was a dog I'm like
the black sheep of the family so I'm
like the party
you know
um jail prison life but I mean I went to
school I graduated high school and I got
an A Community College in business and I
know how to do home appraisals you know
I know a lot of them
people that are in real estate
um that we uh you know have connections
but I'm a felon now so I can't really
work oh wow I didn't have to work under
the table I'm sorry to become a felon
all right
um how the wrong crowd started hanging
out the wrong crowd
was what was your felony
um
my first felony was probably
211 maybe like a robbery or something
something with a gun charge maybe I
don't know some stupid Vanishing an eye
for something the first time I got oh my
brandishing a knife
on the red line drugs got started for
you at what age
um around 14.
15.
I love it I mean I don't look at it like
uh drugs or like elegant or like it's
like MDMA you know what I'm saying Molly
is to feel good stimulants you know
people look at it like it's codependency
but for me it's like
I'm not really dependent on much you
know myself
even on the streets for how long
um since June 28th I think and like I've
never been on the streets before ever
like
my family was just my grandma passed
away and my grandpa passed away and like
people just kept passing away and so
when I was in prison you know I kept
losing like
um I guess I pushed my I guess I'm like
the reason for that you know people just
started like not caring about like what
I had going on anymore you know um so
you spent time in prison then a lot of
time in prison that's what I have my
life in prison for these for a lot of my
friends you know what I'm saying like I
mean that's just what it is there you
know and it's like here in L.A I only
went to jail one time and that's why I'm
here now is because of the one time that
I went to jail and um
I mean I have no complaints I love La
you know um it's very big it's very fast
OC is very slow yeah and Riverside and
so many other very slow there and in La
it's like we're very fast paced you know
living and uh moving so
um yeah
LA's cool and I'm here and homeless
never running the streets you know I
have a lot of friends I have arrows
everyone you know what I'm saying my
friends are everywhere so
even if I don't look like I'm right
there you know I'm like somewhere else
like a couple days ago I was in um on
San Pedro Street and I was in this like
tiny tiny little bra and I was like for
it was raining outside like snowing it
was like 22 degrees maybe if that and um
they see me and then pass out like like
hovering over the ground like just after
I've done like smoked a bowl or whatever
you know and they tell like people like
it started getting like crazy and I'm
like dude don't get crazy I don't know
there's a bunch of gang bangers in here
it's scary on the streets in L.A yeah
it's Skid Row are you would you consider
yourself trans oh no no no no no girl
you're a girl devil maybe it depends on
what I feel that day
am I supposed to say that what do they
consider me they always ask me are you a
girl or boy I'm like what what kind of
jeans am I wearing like what do you want
to know it's like the same question
everywhere in here by the same people
it's like I'm seeing the same people why
do I see these people so like
you're hanging out in the same
neighborhood I know I mean I am in
Hollywood obvious like another whole
different East LA South La you know West
on North on the same the same people
will be right there asking me the same
questions it's like
[Music]
so your drug is uh crystal meth yeah
methamphetamine
I hate heroin and Fentanyl it's not for
me anymore you know
um it used to do Fentanyl I used to yeah
and I got really sick and I went to ocj
I've been at ocg I'll probably hold the
record of how many times I've been in
ocjocj Orange County Jail those are like
those are on my you know
um original
but it's like
yeah I never will defend all ever again
because I came through one time I was so
sick and I just remembered having like
convulsions I went to Elman which is
limamon which is like for um when you're
like going Drake when you're like gonna
cut your wrist or suicidal and um I was
so sick laying on a mat just shaking and
throwing up and like my body is just
[__] on myself but um I never defend
on again like that I don't care for your
hair did the crystal meth help you get
off fentanyl
um no crystal meth just um helps me uh
Focus I do business better but um here
in this part of town it's just like
everybody wants to go here everybody
wants to go here it's like where where
in am I in you want to do something you
know like
it makes me um
what helped me get off heroin oh
Suboxone
in prison Suboxone
some boxing
how are you supporting yourself now
um you know I have a lot of how do I
support myself a good question
um government I live with the government
right now government support
are you entertaining men
um I haven't I used to know I'm Plenty
of Fish and Backpage no I haven't I
haven't done anything
um I've only had like four really like I
don't even call them relationships just
Partners
um since I've been in La I'm really like
picking
um I don't even think like that honestly
and I used to and it's like what what is
you know meth for you know being in L.A
County Jail yeah make it uh difficult
for you yeah
um depending on what you're looking for
exactly
um easy because it's like um you know I
I don't know I think they make it easy
on themselves right there yeah here they
make it really hard for themselves I
don't know why they make it so hard for
themselves unless they have other
obligations you know and I don't need to
go that far into knowing downtown skin
around but did you have in jails do you
have a lot of boyfriends um I had a few
boyfriends yeah and one not a lot in
prison I had a few
um and they probably can't add more than
a few you know
um
but I don't know I don't really think
about that so back to your family do you
uh what was your childhood like
um by The Beach ocean
by the clubs Always by the beach nice
neighborhood very very very nice so
you're the black sheep of your family
yeah they won't even listen to me my
phone calls anymore they want to take my
phone calls anymore they have their
friends now I know all their friends
friends friends but they won't take much
anymore because they don't want to lose
any money they said that they don't want
to lose uh money by coming around
because
um of some stupid boy or some stupid you
know and it's not stupid and they didn't
say stupid but just they didn't want to
lose little money and they would have
lost a little money but still I mean I
would have been pissed for a dollar I
would have not you know and so
I have to be a self man
um
millionaire I guess not an entrepreneur
but you know everything I have I earn by
myself I had to earn it like my friends
put it there to see if I earned it you
know how do you make money
I still do promise else promotional I
mean like Club promotional then you know
I get loans
and um
people even give um loans out
I give my friends out loans for other
businesses you know what I'm saying I
give them promo like promotionals and
they um
you know but you're living on the street
I am kind of not really kind of at times
it depends on what I'm doing
in the sale if I'm like really dedicated
and I really have to go all the way with
it then yeah I'll be on the street so
it's like two weeks I'll be standing and
I won't go to sleep and I'm only yeah
you want to sleep for two weeks no but
I'll be changing every like you know
when it's time to change I'll be in a
new outfit right away
what's the longest you've stayed awake
um here probably I haven't without them
sitting on me
um it's actually getting better like two
weeks now two weeks without sleep yeah
two weeks as long as ever and then when
you finally do something not here when
you finally do fall asleep how long do
you sleep for
um about not that many hours like an
hour maybe like in this one um probably
like eight hours
not that many hours and I'm all right
I'm right right back my head goes right
back
you know people have problems with that
and there's like they go to sleep and
they wake up and it's like it's over and
it's
um never over for me you know I hear it
all the time I'm hearing right now like
have you ever been in love yeah I've
been in love before they just took a
love from me
I'm sorry they just took some of my
lives right now yeah I've been in love
that was cool
is that what I'm supposed to say love
yes love no I have not been in love
oh geez
so you grew up a boy yeah I grew up at
what age did you realize that you were
um around eight or 12 years old
how'd your family take that
um like I said though I was adopted so
they didn't really have much to say and
I'm saying I didn't know what happened
you know all I knew was like that's all
I know you know what I'm saying and
I don't know anything else that's all I
know and
my family they like really don't have
much to say about like the decisions
that I make you know my grandmother and
sheenan but um I just listened to her
because she's my friend you know and um
my grandpa he didn't he's my friend he
kept me up on um everything you know did
you feel like something happened to you
as a kid or you were born this way yeah
I think that uh something happened to me
when I was like 15 or something
and like something came you know I'm
saying something happened to me then
my friends something happened to me or
my friends
some sexual abuse or something like that
no no sexual abuse never I wish no
I don't believe in that stuff people
always see like crazy sick things and
I'm like I see everything and um none of
it bothers me not once like I don't care
what kind of stuff do you see on the
streets
nothing you see of having pizza parties
out there every day or how are they
having all those pizzas and where where
do I come from like when I come down the
street and I'm like where's my pizza and
like all there'll be like hundreds of
boxes of pieces in the trash can and
like cakes and like candies I'm like
what is going on timing is everything
that makes me really um
I laugh like they must be going wild out
there you know what I'm saying I miss
everything I'm like call me up what's
going on do you have any friends yeah I
have a lot of friends you do yeah a
couple they're on the streets as well
um they can't meet
they will be anything if they have to me
you know we all know me if they have to
be what's been your experience on the
streets too
um I've seen a lot of like uh gang bang
stuff I I remember that real hard with
it my experience on the streets is
[Music]
they don't really know it gays don't
really know it
um
people friends don't really care like
nothing
that's my experience but you know
I know what I mean is jail or prison
easier or better than being on the
street um I think president Jones harder
because
um I have to sit there and talk and some
days I'm like I have really bad days and
that's what they were trying to do like
and I was like really scared like I had
a lump in my throat like some things are
really um
good and then some days I'm like certain
people come in front of me and they're
like what's wrong and I'll be at the
wall like you know or at the toilet I
have to stand at the toilet and like
count like I have to like pray or like
make up an excuse of what I'm doing
because I'm losing my mind
um and
it's like bad for me I have to mandatory
work out I have to do mandatory programs
so I'll have to do like you know sets
don't have to read so I have to clean
the house so and it's like sometimes
it's just like
right man good luck to me on that you
know not just being a jake out I mean
but really programming so jcat is what
mentally off yeah
I guess it was immensely off and I'm
someone who is um
EOP
somebody's sick so you've done you've
done a prison time what kind of stuff
got you in prison
uh
I think it's funny um in prison but but
I was yellow you know I'll speak up on
their behalf because I feel bad when
people like don't understand around them
you know what I'm saying I don't feel
bad for them I have no feeling for them
but I just want to make it like get it
right you know like those are not eops
the reason they're sick is because you
know the [__] that they're saying they
don't mean any ambitious they're the
same like that person individually does
it you know maybe everybody around us
want to say something and I'll say it
too like [__] you you know what I'm
saying if that's the case if no one's
gonna speak up you know and um but
prison I think prisons there's more
like crazy like you have to be careful
because it'll stop you when what if
offenses got you in into prison or jail
um and just a lot of like uh robberies
and four five nines and vehicle thefts
with the prior you know I know how to
hotwire a car really quick and any wires
I know how to wire everything up so and
um
what else that's it nothing weird
nothing about oh and drugs but not
really drugs because I never sold drugs
I don't sell drugs I just use them never
know I sell drugs um
but I know where they're all at all
times
um I don't sell I don't make money like
that and no prostitution or anything
like that so
and that's that what's your biggest fear
my biggest fear is
to not
I don't have an affair right now
I don't know drowning them
knocking the Drone down here oh yeah all
right and drowning
um
believing
losing do you picked on being being
trans down here no that's weird it's
because I know them all
I have a smokes with all of these pools
in the house I know every one of them I
know all of them
from here to you know
888 what's that [__] street called
Los Angeles or Hill or spring I know
everyone
and where they're all at all times and
they they
leave you alone they know we partying
like we sometimes they're cool sometimes
recently in the beginning we're having
good times we were all laughing you know
they wanted me to step up in the butt
like when I took the Metro
um they're like oh come up and talk to
me and let me explain to you what's
going on you know and then all of a
sudden it just turned me and so now
we're all mean and mad and angry and so
I think it's funny either or I know them
all I know that I know exactly how
they're you know yelling at people or
what they're trying to think I don't
care I'm just like shut up you know I'm
still the same I get angry when I like
and they're cool I mean they shouldn't
be nice
I'm dirty 30.
you're turning 30. yeah um I just turned
33 in November 33. I don't treat them
nice though you know
I'll go and break all their [__] if I
want to break all their [__] I'll laugh
on their pants I'll call them you know I
know when too what kind of things do you
go through emotionally living like this
oh my gosh I don't think I'm ever
emotionally in a sleep deprivation I
don't know
um
unemotional I'm not really emotional
you're not
does the the crystal meth help you with
that
um it helps me a little um for it just
for a little bit it makes me um
it blocks it out because I get a better
stimulant and changes my stimulant
you know so I feel differently what does
crystal meth do for you
um it keeps me Focus
he's doing like makes me laugh it makes
my hair it um blinds my friends for a
little bit you know it makes them throw
them off
for me it's done nothing it's good so
far I'm waiting so hopefully tonight
yeah
bad things bad things happen to you here
on the street no nothing bad happens
I've seen bad things happen to people
though on the streets in the warehouses
everywhere I've seen it everywhere I'm
it's part of those are like some of my
really really good friends
and I don't discriminate you know
against anything I've seen it all I hear
it all at all times if I wanted to
um I think it's perfect you know like TV
just don't never make you better would
you describe yourself as happy yeah I'm
happy I'm um
I'm very Smiley I'm smiling happy I'm
not happy
I'm real
[Music]
where would you like to be in five years
um in five years I like TV in my own pet
in that studio I like to be in a loft my
own Loft and um summer in Texas Maybe
do you have any regrets in your life
oh my gosh
I think everything makes you stronger
right
hopefully you learn from your mistakes
Macy's stronger right or it doesn't kill
you makes you stronger maybe it's
because um you're gonna get past this
and get stronger and stronger
you need me die and get stronger
yeah I regret um
and knowing some certain people you know
Zoe what would you say is the most
important lesson you've learned in your
life
not to carrying a weapon around
all right Zoe thank you so much for
sharing your story thank you yes nice
talking to you